previously on TV sins so do you think we
can keep a lid on this for now I don't
want to worry people unnecessary
[Music]
this is about the most conspicuously
inconspicuous handoff of all time would
have been less noticeable if she tucked
it down his shirt with her teeth also is
this how they get secret jobs at a bar
with a belly dancer as a go-between the
belly dancer didn't even have a note
when she went behind the wall so you're
basically 5 feet from whoever handed the
to her anyway
a third party seems a bit of a waste at
this point just drop it on the floor and
leave if you don't want to take a couple
extra steps nice work dumbass but isn't
that good for Jane not like he and mal
or a team in this scenario you didn't
toast
I would even know that mal was clear
across the bar and the guy got a couple
of years of essed
I think a lot of people didn't toast
thinking you weren't burdened with an
overabundance of schooling so why don't
we just ignore each other till we go
away Nathan in Killian George in show
good quite like that ginger with the
lead character is charismatic as Captain
Mal and Whedon quipping the quips it's
absolutely a sin that they don't
subtitle the Mandarin in the show now I
have to spend $100 on rosetta stone and
years of my life to learn the language
so I can fully enjoy one of the greatest
shows of all time so that's not an
actual window and you can be thrown
through it like that how effective could
it possibly be seems like it would be
pretty easy for people to break into
your place or what if it rains or an
animal decides to wander in I'm thinking
will rise again how did they pull off
the serenity now maneuver when there was
no way that ship could have snuck below
them without being seen and heard first
seeing these scenes from the actual
pilot of the show in the opening credits
is as good a time as any to sin how
badly Fox screwed up the release burying
it on Friday nights playing episodes out
of order marketing it as a screwball
comedy the show's promo tagline was out
there oh it's out there what the hell
Fox You Know Who I am
the weak link in an otherwise incredible
cast standard radio an accelerator core
class code 0 3 - K 6 4 she got all this
from standing in a medical Bay need a
weave on that it's nothing true so if
you're not putting anything on it why on
earth did you walk all the way to the
medical room to just wash your hands I'm
assuming you do have sinks elsewhere in
this [ __ ] right now
Wow acting captain how's the girl
couldn't shepard go find this out for
himself since she's literally about 20
feet away from him give up everything to
free his sister from that place
folks position I'm wondering why a man
so anxious to fly under Alliance radar
with how's known
fugitives Barney Miller's Ron glass
would be excellent at TV sins shouldn't
you be off bringin religiosity the
fuzzy-wuzzies or some such that suppose
II was just do you think it looks better
up we can experiment we might even get
wild later and wash your face the scene
alone is solely responsible for 73% of
all fanfiction written in the early 21st
century but physical appearance doesn't
matter so terribly this line was set on
a television show with zero sense of
irony have you seen your cast poster how
other face oh you do not like I kill
this man hmm
oh no I'm sure he was a very bad person
my wife's nephew familial discourse Oh
a dream job role commercials now he's
not the first psycho to hires no the
last seems like an awfully bold
conversation to be having in a crowded
train car with lots of listening ears
nearby
I do feel awfully useless don't worry
book I'm sure if jaws ever gets to make
a movie we will really get your chance
to shine lower Jane on to the car and
they bundle up the booty haul them all
back up easy as a lion easy as a lion
why would he take on trouble like those
two weren't no profit in it even if Jane
isn't aware River is listening Simon
literally just walked away and could
easily hear all this seems like there
would be some sort of security on the
train that would be aware of a spaceship
tracking them for the last hour or so
and call it in to someone I'm all about
the way this show combines sci-fi space
travel and a Western motif but even if
this random planet just happens to
terraform to look like the deserts of
Arizona why are there old-style
electricity bowls alongside this track I
stole the car in medicine sure is go
around convenient that our mal pal here
just happened to end up next to these
two and hear what they stole so we could
proceed with this episode's moral
quandary six crates of Pascal and D
right I'll get you a tiny fortune of
black market
good thing we took a few minutes to
visit this discount empire base to tell
us something we already knew and also is
explain later but they ain't the ones
who stole the medicine but how does grab
a quill know this I get that he
apparently suspects these two but
without any evidence and as valuable as
the stuff is couldn't really have been
just about anyone know what the chain of
command is it's a great two-part episode
of Star Trek The Next Generation where
the card is kidnapped by mrs. Jane
talking top bullsh begin isn't it
Cardinal
don't think of one of them saver Cena
registered companion before there
probably is a sin here button are kind
of made me forget what my job
thank you very much Sheriff come along
companions truly are this respected and
this would work this easily why did it
take them so long to think of this
option shouldn't she be plan a on every
job you didn't make their undies off and
yet here you are strolling up to a ship
as if you knew where it would be all so
who needs a rendezvous point right oh
look at that fancy space gun it almost
looks like a modern camera held by a
regular dude and a white t-shirt and
tennis shoes the future man crazy and
the last thing you see will be my lady
darn Oh awesome we didn't fly 86 million
miles to track down a box of band-aids
colonel and a brand bandages you mean
band-aid brand bandages go are a madman
to show his intelligent hilarious and
unique for the charming cast that has
incredible chemistry and we will be
enjoying it for many seasons to come
good thing it's not going anywhere some
people call me a terrorist I consider
myself a teacher we're on a ship were
there monkeys some terrifying space
monkeys maybe got loose sure
and monkeys might fly out of my butt I'm
gonna make him an offer again oh hey
doctor doctor doctor doctor doctor
doctor darn